DC Comics is the Joker just standing
here in the street corner and his
hideous Joker makeup in public or does
he put that bit on sometime during the
height this guy totally ducks but the
other guy still shoots where his head
would have been if he hadn't done the
bus's behind the Joker's bust to not
notice the additional busts breaking the
line and coming out of the huge gaping
hole in the bank why does Batman keep
meeting with Gordon on rooftops so low
that half the skyscrapers in town can
see and photograph the meetings where is
the tumbler busting in from there like
eight levels up in a parking garage why
does the band stop the very second
Batman makes impact how the fuck is
Batman supposed to have gotten into the
vault without being seen is there a back
door somewhere out there's a company
making money selling useless frosted
glass divider panels that don't provide
security or actual room division this
witness manages to get a gun into court
in a major organized crime case and is
also apparently just holding that his
lap and full view of the judge Rachel's
all turned on by people trying to kill
Harvey Dent but wouldn't go out with
Batman because the same she there are no
cameras in this room but Lao can see
everything anyway can you put the eraser
end of a pencil through someone's head I
want Vsauce on this right now
beautiful guard shrugs off the fact that
Lucius has a cellphone that should have
been confiscated and then shrugs off the
fact that he thinks all black people
look alike so no ring I was going to say
bat Communist China apparently has no
rules about the airspace over Hong Kong
and any old smuggler plane can fly
within 50 feet of buildings Joker card
had traces of your DNA wasn't semen I
bet it was semen it can be said the
characters Heath Ledger played during
his career where Gyllenhaal is sexual
look I know he's Batman and everything
but he managed to make it past everyone
including the Joker's henchmen without
anyone seeing and I guess having four
screens of the same Joker broadcast
somehow helps Batman Bruce Wayne has the
technology to reconstruct fingerprints
from a shattered bullet that went
through a brick so why hasn't he also
invented time travel or a woman who has
orgasms
Harvey is known rachel is next since the
daytime shooting but waits until night
time to tell her about Harvey Dent drove
to this random spot to question this
crazy guy and Batman's been busy beating
up Maroni so how does he know where Dent
is just think chef Thomas when did
Batman have a chance to find out who
this crazy dude really was since he was
whisked away before anyone could
question are you sure you want Rachel
Bruce she doesn't even look like she did
in the first movie how does the room
know that they're leaving and it's kind
of inconvenient that becomes darker as
you try to position yourself on this
platform do they really need to go down
to lower fifth surely there are plenty
of other ways to get to their
destination really you are a SWAT
officer Batmobile clearly landing on its
back but then instantly up right for the
next shot how does the Joker know
exactly which route the cops will take
so that he's able to set up this
helicopter trap Batman blows away all
these cars without knowing if anyone is
in them
Gordon faked his death to protect his
family but how does he keep that a
secret when there are so many corrupt
cops on the payroll he even manages to
get on the SWAT team without anyone
tipping off the Joker and what did they
tell his wife sorry your husband has
been shot but you can't see the body
because his face is so disfigured he
looks like Gary Oldman you do like to
play things pretty close to the chest
wait he never said that that was Bruce
that said that the Fox claimed this one
pretty close to the chest do you weren't
even there back from the dead like I
told you I was playing this one close to
the chest she's gonna have to play my
little game you wanna say isn't this
just the decision the Riddler made
Batman make in Batman Forever only on a
larger scale talk me through what's
going on with you looking relationships
man jeez Joker's plan to break Lao out
of prison requires him to be able to get
rid of Batman and Gordon so that he can
make a phone call and blow this dude and
this prison up there's simply no way the
Joker could have known precisely when
police would realize dent was gone when
they would interrogate him about it when
Batman enjoined the questioning and when
things would escalate to a beating
meaning there's no way he could have had
timers on the bombs for Rachel and
Harvey that would be timed so perfectly
for Batman just in that moment to have
only enough time to rescue one of them
Batman doesn't even know Rachel had this
coin on her when she died but somehow
finds it in the rubble
wouldn't the ferryboat workers have
noticed all these explosives during
preparation before they left come on if
this were any other third-rate villain
Batman would be able to get out of this
my turn two-face decides people's fates
by the flip of a coin so wouldn't it
make sense that he goes last between
Batman Gordon's son and himself
I just never know what he did five dead
two of them cops
I count three people in one cop he shot
the cop from the fugitive and he only
punched Ramirez he shot the driver of
the car Maroni was in CC it's not nearly
as bad as you think Frank why doesn't
spawn kill me bullshit like he didn't
issue 100 he even calls him freak isn't
that a secret identity